new Macs are here and it's time to find
out the truth for you guys we have five
here we have seven more coming in so
make sure you guys are subscribed and in
front of me I have the new M2 Pro
MacBook Pro and we already found a bunch
of things that other reviewers did not
mention both good and bad so in this
video not only are you going to take a
look at the exterior differences and
physical ones which yes there are
multiples but we're also going to test
out the CPU performance the graphics
performance throttling fan noise and
heat along with battery life because
both these are charged to a hundred
percent so let's go ahead and unplug
these and get into this ultimate
comparison now the laptops themselves
look identical but we have some
differences first off the power cable
now comes with a matching Max save
connector which is nice if you're
getting space gray with that the empty
Pro MacBooks HDMI port is a lot more
powerful the M1 Pro does 4K 60hz now
we're up to 4K 240Hz which is better
than any other system out there along
with AK 60hz now unfortunately we still
don't have face ID inside of that large
Notch but one thing that reviewers did
mention is that the webcam did get
better taking a look at these two side
by side the empty Pros 1080p webcam is a
little bit cooler it looks a lot sharper
and it just looks better overall because
of the new M2 Pro chips ISP so that is a
benefit now we also have differences in
speakers which nobody mentioned now I'll
let you guys hear the difference but
first I want to mention that we are not
only giving away a 14 inch MacBook Pro
but also a Mac Mini and all you have to
do is one be subscribed to enable
notifications and three comment down
below and you can watch your previous M2
Pro MacBook launch videos and comment
there and our new ones all the way up to
February 1st which is when we are going
to be announcing the winner so good luck
to all of you guys out there and now
let's go ahead and take a listen to the
speaker differences
[Music]
now I'm not sure if you guys can hear
the difference even with our 850 dollar
microphone setup but the older M1 Pro
14-inch has brighter highs and it sounds
louder as well compared to the new M2
pro version now Apple actually did this
with the M2 MacBooks where the highs are
brought down they're more muted and
Vadim and I both definitely prefer the
older 14-inch MacBook Pro especially for
vocals and movies and things like that
let us know which one you prefer down in
the comment section below now we've also
heard talks of Apple downgrading the
internals of the M2 Pro 14 inch so we're
gonna take the bottoms off and look at
that but before I get into that I've got
to talk about the best maxi iPhone case
I've ever seen the magic stand case from
our partner K school not only is it
surprisingly slim and durable but it
comes with a very strong 40 8 magnet Max
a freeing that actually doubles as a
stand just pull out the ring to use it
as a finger grip or as a stand for
watching videos at any angle between 40
and 120 degrees and the best part is
that it folds back completely flush with
the case so you can still use it with
your Maxim charges and accessories so
use the link down below to get 23 off
your order today we have the M1 Pro
right there on the left side and on the
right let's take a look at the M2 Pro
all right and Vadim what's up look at
that what is that
it's confirmed not only is the M2
MacBook Pro and empty MacBook Air
consumer devices for people to do web
browsing and email slow down in terms of
SSD but this two thousand dollar 14 inch
MacBook Pro nobody can argue this time
that it's such fine because it's for
consumers that don't do anything on a
2000 Pro device we have one SSD chip
memory chip right here instead of two on
the M1 Pro you guys could see there's
four spaces for them if you have a two
terabyte one and above you'll have all
of them filled whereas this time we
still have four spaces but they're only
using one now if you look at the prices
for these chips they're fairly
inexpensive but a single 512 is barely
any more expensive than having a 256 gig
and then of course those you have to buy
two of them which is why apple is just
using one that also saves time on
getting these installed labor all of
that kind of stuff so that is a
disappointment we're gonna see how much
of a speed performance difference that
actually makes I also want to mention
the Wi-Fi this new Mt Pro comes with
Wi-Fi 6E finally and better Bluetooth so
I actually spent a ton of money
upgrading my home Wi-Fi in order to be
able to test this out and see how big of
a difference does that actually make so
make sure you guys are subscribed for
that now most other things look the same
but there's one big difference that I
just noticed look at the heat sink this
copper cover or aluminum that is over
the M1 Pro and the Mt Pro it is way
bigger on the M1 Pro this thing is Tiny
and this section right here this little
tape that's covering a little metal
guard the actual metal part that has the
heat is literally what do you think
would even half the size
close to half the size now we are going
to run some thermal tests see does it
get hotter does it get louder because of
that there's less Mass that's connecting
uh that's covering that chip and that
heat can hold into that definitely has
me a little bit concerned now this is
the base model of course but you can get
more cores with the same exact setup so
we'll be testing uh higher end
configuration soon and now that they're
back together let's test out the SSD
speeds I'm using amorphous diskmark 4.0
gives a lot more info than blackmagics
test and right away we could see that
actual ssds are different we have this
one ending at R here with the new one
ends in z let's go ahead and run this oh
my goodness vadine whoa no way
that is sad
with the Mt Pro it's still fast way
faster than the M2 base MacBooks or Mac
Mini but look at that insane difference
in sequential speeds now this one runs a
bunch of tests with different block
sizes we have almost seven thousand here
6981 compared to 3462 for the read and
then for their write speed
5763 compared to 33.73 almost half the
speed for the new 2 000 M2 MacBook Pro
now I have to say that in this machine
you have 16 gigs of RAM you're not going
to run into swap as often but we do know
it still does run into Swap and being
able to read that data almost twice as
fast can impact the performance and
people said that for those base MacBooks
like them two MacBook Air most people
don't use that for productivity it's a
cheaper device cheaper but this is a two
thousand dollar Pro machine so here's a
full breakdown for you guys and what I'm
personally really curious about is does
the 16 inch 2500 model also have ssds
that are way slower or is it the same
performance as it was previously with
the 16 inch we will find that out soon
now I want to give you guys an update on
the battery life before I get into the
tough benchmarks because we've been
shooting for a while now doing a bunch
of various simple tasks and the M1 Pro
is at 92 percent battery life and the M2
Pro is at 96 so we're already seeing a
difference with those efficiency cores
being much better and having four
instead of two now I also noticed now
that we have a low power mode on this
2021 14 inch M1 Pro so I'm gonna go and
disable that but even with low power
mode it sucked more power than the M2
and auto alright guys we have geekbench
5 opened up right here and the first
thing I want to point out is look at
that clock speed different friends we
have 3.2 for the M1 Pro and 3.49 for the
M2 Pro but with that with the leaked
benchmarks we saw that the M2 Max some
of them showed 3.67 so I wonder is Apple
actually different the CPU performance
now between them where last year you
would have the same CPU even with the M1
Pro we will find out soon but for now
let's go ahead and run the CPU Benchmark
all right guys wow even in geekbench
which is easy I'm already seeing a
difference in temperature 71 compared to
54 so we'll see what we get in cinebench
and look at that score right there we
have a 10 increase in single core score
which exactly lines up with just raising
the clock speed a little bit higher so
that's just a clock speed difference and
in multi-core we have a difference of 20
just like apple said and that's because
of the clock speeds plus the extra more
powerful efficiency cores let's see what
that difference makes for web browsing
performance with all your web-based
applications and here we go 361 compared
to 412 that's a 14 different so slightly
more this involves memory and other
things as well and these are incredible
scores for both of these and now we're
going to take it further because this
year we are adding a whole nother test
for you Graphics designers this is figma
provided to us by one of the best design
agencies 500 designs let's go ahead and
zoom in here and see how smooth that is
so many applications that are now
web-based and it's super convenient and
so far pretty smooth I do see stuff
taken a little bit to refresh
here I don't know does that look any
smoother
hard to tell me they both have the same
amount of RAM and this is going to be
great for our Ram comparison videos
let's zoom in to one of these pages and
see how long it takes to give you full
quality
as you can see bam that was a few
seconds to let up we had a little bit of
glitchiness let's see if the M2 Pro is
any better
as you guys see it is a little smoother
and as far as refreshing and giving us
the full quality it's about the same and
now I selected 12 of these high
resolution web pages and we are going to
do an export test let's go ahead and get
started alright guys that is done and we
have a minute 57 seconds for the M1 Pro
and a minute and 37 seconds for the M2
Pro which if you do the math it's a 20
difference that lines up perfectly to
our multi-core and geekbench so for you
guys that use web-based applications you
will see a 14 to 20 Improvement in
performance which is great so now let's
really hit the CPU hards with cinebench
and I want to give a shout out to TG fan
Pro we provide them with the analytics
from these systems and they updated the
software for us so we can give you guys
the best value and the best information
now before we start our 10 minute
throttling test I'm going to check the
temps we have 26 Celsius and 26 Celsius
so exactly the same and now let's get
started so our CPUs are maxed out it's
been running for a little bit I have my
info here but I want to point out that
the new M2 Pro is already 98 99 degrees
celsius compared to 92 so definitely
heating up more so now the clock speed
is higher running at 3.264 megahertz
compared to 3.06 about 230 250 megahertz
faster now we're hitting 102 on this bad
boy and that is because these do use
more power we have an average of 21.8
Watts on the M1 Pro and 26 Watts on the
M2 that's about 20 percent more power
that is being used for this 3D render
and we have a difference of 103 degrees
celsius compared to 93 degrees Celsius
and with that our fans are running at
the slowest speed for the M1 Pro
compared to 3 300 RPM and it looks like
it's still ramping up so it's been about
seven minutes let's check on temps you
guys see those hot spots and we're
looking like 43 is the hottest on the M1
Pro
and about 44 on the M2 Pro now looks
like the hot spot is more concentrated
that's probably because the thermal
block is smaller so we are almost done
with the 10 minute test here and I do
want to say that I don't hear the fans
on either systems so even though the
empty Pro runs hotter and the fans spin
up louder you can't tell now with that
said these are the band based models so
what's gonna happen if we have the
unbend one which has uh eight
performance cores instead of six and
then what if you throw an extra Graphics
tasks at the same time that could get
bad so we're gonna test it out along
with the crazy M2 Max gym now these just
got done right here we have
9490 on the M1
and 11 714 on the M2 Pro now that is 23
faster under load which is excellent
that's slightly higher than the quoted
performance and the system at least this
one was able to handle it and of course
a part of that performance is because
not only do the efficiency course clock
hire about 350 megahertz higher we also
have four instead of two which adds up
to this and now let's get into graphics
performance we have 3D Marks Wildlife
extreme in the unlimited mode and we're
gonna see how the new 16 core Graphics
stack up to 14 core right away I'm
seeing that not only do we have extra
cores but it's actually running at 1398
megahertz compared to 1296 so about 100
megahertz higher clock speed now the
wattage only went up by three and a half
Watts so it's not that much and with our
scores here we have 54.9 FPS compared to
67.2 that that is 22 percent better
performance which does seem a little bit
underwhelming but you also have to
remember that this is the bin one we
have two extra cores compared to that
one whereas the unbend which you get for
300 bucks that actually gives you three
extra cores compared to the previous
unbid so you're actually getting one
extra core for the extra money this year
and it's gonna be a bigger difference in
performance and now let's do a quick gfx
bench test because we know that it
scales well and we have our results I
ran both the 1440p and the new 4k test
as far as 1440p we have
144.4 FPS compared to 180.6 with the M2
Pro that gives us a 25 Improvement which
is slightly better than 3dmark and then
for the 4K one we have 63.4 compared to
78.6 FPS 24 better so pretty good
scaling there now we wanted to test
xcode for all of you coders out there
but right now because of the update
dates and stuff it's not running with
our terminal which is the way we
Benchmark it for consistency so we will
give you guys the scores in another
video but now we're gonna test out
blender 3D rendering performance we have
the classic BMW test rendering using
metal and let's see what we get wow the
M2 Pro is flying through this compared
to the M1 I think this one finally was
finished two minutes and three seconds
for the M1 Pro and a minute 25 for the
M2 Pro both Bend and that's the
difference of 45 percent
that is impressive what do you think
Vadim that's killer we went from 22 and
now with blender that is huge that is a
significant difference and I'm wondering
how much of a difference will we have
with the new M2 Pro unbend M2 Max
because we talked about the whole tlb
issue how for high high-res files and
certain programs there would be
limitations to scaling and I don't know
if this is what's fixing it but that is
very impressive and now for your photo
editors we're testing out Adobe
Lightroom now zooming in and switching
photos was always pretty quick with both
systems you guys could see we don't have
a huge difference now another thing I
want to test out is all the new AI based
stuff so right now I'm going to select
the sky at the same time let's see how
long that takes to detect it and it
looks like it took about a second faster
with this new one and that's probably
using the neural engine as well now what
I'm going to do is go ahead and Export
all these and in the set settings I did
make sure that the graphics was enabled
so we have 50 42 megapixel raw files all
of them are edited with a bunch of
changes we're gonna export to JPEG and
let's see how quick these are very
interesting here I'm seeing lower CPU
usage Windows spiking up on the M2 Pro
here now I'm not sure if it's correct
but this one looked like it got done
fast I actually missed that for a second
so I'm going to go ahead and try that
one more time bam we are off
no distractions this time all right this
time the M2 Pro did win but barely 49
seconds compared to
52. now when I looked at acetop it did
show that we were using swap on both of
them and we know the ssds are slower
here and being only three seconds faster
I would expect more because we obviously
saw big differences in CPU and GPU
performance with those other benchmarks
but those are not writing files
constantly to your SSD while it's doing
all that processing so that's very
interesting we're going to look into
that more and now let's take a look at
video editing now even the M1 Pro had no
issues with regular 4K compressed
footage here I have a couple Luts I have
foam grain applied no issues whatsoever
but what I'm curious about is will it be
faster to export and as far as general
processing I'm going to go ahead and
Export this five minute project
let's hit save and start a timer alright
guys so it looks like we are not getting
any performance difference for encoding
4K video files that are compressed uh 94
on both 95 it's exactly the same in the
limitation are the actual encoders there
so 2 minutes 22 seconds uh practically
exactly what we got before now of course
this is easier we're not limited by the
graphics or the CPU just encoders and
apple they have not changed them at
least on this system so if you're
working with simple 4K it's probably not
worth upgrading but what if you make it
harder this is 4K prores raw that is
graded and we're going to export to
prores because these systems do have
dedicated encoders for that and let's
hit save so these machines are flying
through this and it looks like the M2
Pro is faster but not by that much the
M2 is limited by graphics and here we're
almost maxing it out but not all the way
that was super quick on both systems and
we have a difference of a minute and
eight seconds for the M1 Pro and a
minute and three seconds for the M2 Pro
so what five seconds difference or so uh
very very little difference
um that's a little bit underwhelming
because for a lot of YouTubers a lot of
people that use these systems you're
doing photo editing video editing and
we're just not seeing a massive
difference like we did in those
benchmarks and other tasks so we will be
doing more testing on systems that don't
have the slower SSD speed to see how
much of a difference we have there
digging into more programs and more
tests and tougher things as well than
these tests that we did for this base
Bend 14 inch comparison
if you guys let us know uh what was the
most interesting thing for you what
surprised you are you okay with the SSD
thing uh what about those temperatures
but lastly let's go ahead and check out
our battery life differences we had
tough usage where the Mt Pro used more
wattage but then the lighter stuff we
have the efficiency course so I'm very
curious and it looks like we have 33
battery life remaining during all this
time which is still pretty good let's
check out the M2 Pro and that is 43 on
there so a 10 extra bonus in battery
life which for light usage that could be
an extra hour right there even though we
did a bunch of benchmarks and tough
tests and hit it hard so those
efficiency cores are definitely coming
in handy so there you guys go don't
forget to watch the other ones the
previous ones and the ones after this
and comments for a chance to win the 14
inch MacBook Pro or a Mac Mini check out
one of those great videos right over
there this has been Max and I'll see you
in the next one
[Music]